[Music]
hong kong just will become
another province
in china any new ideas or new
new voice will be crashed there needs to
be the other
the first second third and fourth other
lewis hamilton's coming up there's so
many different
opportunities but they're not told about
this they don't know how to get into it
it was a fantastic experience and we we
loved every day every day was a
different adventure
meeting so many people around the world
it was it was it was brilliant
being able to turn to music in times
like these is so important
we're all just finding our way like all
of this and we're all feeling for our
fellow humans around the world and just
hoping to try to stay safe and do the
best job we all can
[Music]
well since the carnivorous pandemic
began artist ai weiwei has launched
himself into creative and humanitarian
projects
in june he raised over 1 million pounds
selling face coverings he designed to
help support the work of global
charities fighting coronavirus
and now he's unveiled his latest work at
the imperial war museum
history of bombs is a display of 50
life-size bombs that replicate those
jews and conflicts
and wars over the last 100 years and ai
weiwei
joins me now from berlin firstly why did
you decide to get involved with the
imperial war museum
i think it's a very good location and
for many reasons it focuses on the
the military
practice of the history and
there's so much to be
learned and also so many so many things
need to be aware
of you do think people
uh need to be aware and those things
have to be
physically uh almost
like touchable or you stand on it you
know and those
are real size bombs and you only hear
it from a news but to to at
this kind of close range and it means
very different interesting to get your
thoughts about the situation currently
in hong kong we've seen the arrests of
pro-democracy activists we've also seen
the disqualification
of people from the um legislative
election process i mean what do you make
of
the crackdown that we are seeing um in
hong kong
china uh using this national security
law
i think that is the surviving gain
chinese government government is playing
but to put it in hong kong which is such
a
heavy heavy-handed law i think
many many people while facing
uh to be either in jail or
exiled or to be silent how bad could it
get
for people in hong kong and also what
does that mean for the relationship
between
china and the west
i think hong kong just will become
another province
in china that means any
freedom of speech or or human rights
condition
will be very heavily restricted under
chinese law so any new ideas or new
new voice will be crashed
[Music]
formula one is organizing an anti-racism
protest before sunday's british grand
prix
the organization was criticized for its
response to the black lives matter
protests
some drivers have taken knee in
solidarity with the protests before the
races
held since the return of the season
lewis hamilton the first and only black
formula one driver
said there was a lack of leadership on
racism and that the issue had
quotes gone off the agenda well i'm
joined now by carol glenn the first
black woman to become a race official
in motorsport in the uk thanks very much
for being
with us uh carol you've carved out a
career in the sport
but i see you written recently or said
recently that
that you know the sport is embedded with
racism or racism is embedded in
motorsport
absolutely definitely i mean i've been
in it 32 years now and
um along the way i've had my i've had my
issues or experiences of racism being
has happened to me directly to me
so it is definitely and this is the
grassroots level but even at formula one
level
and what form carol has that racism
taken that you've experienced
it's been sometimes what they people
call banter you know saying things to me
uh making out that i'm a gangster say
things like you know watch out she might
pinch your tires or
pinch your stereo try talking in a
jamaican accent which i don't
have how can you get more black
drivers more black uh engineers more
black officials
in in motorsport well it's it's like
you know again letting people know what
what options there are for them i've
actually just started
off trying to start an academy now i've
got about 13 youngsters
who are in cartoon and never hit
um the barriers are trying to move on
and i'm not trying to try to
push them on now and um and i'm hoping
that we can also tap into
into the uh the initiative that lewis
has launched with the royal academy of
engineers
and also i i'm quite able to go out to
schools and try to explain some of these
children in schools you know boys and
girls that they can get into you know
engineering
designing being a driver there's so many
different opportunities but they're not
told about this
they don't know how to get into it right
so just 10 seconds left i mean do you
think this could be a moment that could
promote change that you want to see
absolutely
absolutely and i and you know that there
needs to be the other that the first
second third and fourth other lewis
hamilton's coming up
[Music]
well this week the government turned its
attention to tackling obesity with plans
to curb junk food advertising
and promotional deals the celebrity chef
jamie oliver is a prominent
campaigner in the fight against obesity
and told me the new strategy was
surprising
but welcome we've been working in this
area for the last five years since
chapter one of the childhood obesity
strategy
um and i think what we have now is a
nice platform to really get on with
business and really start doing all the
things that matter
in supporting our most vulnerable
communities so
yeah this is about every child and of
course it goes from the schools
um to the high street and a lot of these
initiatives have been driven by the
public
there's obviously a correlation between
being morbidly obese
and being more susceptible to the
serious parts of having covered
and that seems to be perhaps the launch
pad for this initiative
yeah look i i think often in history um
awful things and crises
uh allow you to sort of take stock um
and maybe refocus on some stuffs some
stuff that they always knew about
um like i say this strategy has been
going on for five years and it's taken
boris to sort of pull it off the shelf
and get it back into working order uh
it's the beginning
and he says that in his in his release
but yeah
i think it's undoubtedly covert 19 has
amplified the emotions it's amplified
the science
and it's amplified the need to make sure
that our british children
for all the reasons are as fit as
possible
and ready to be as productive as
possible just to give you kind of
clarity into why do we care and why is
it utterly important to everyone in this
country
uh no matter where they come from if
you're a kid
um and you're from a poor background
you're over twice as likely to be
overweight or obese
we know that that tracks into teenage
years and early adulthood
we know that that has correlation with
low educational attainment
we know it means that on average you get
paid less you have more days absenteeism
cost the state more and end up dying
slightly younger
than your well-off counterpart so there
is a kind of
an inequality story here evening the
playing field and really about
making sure that we're putting as much
support where it's needed
you've got quite a brood haven't you i'm
always curious to have people with lots
of children how they coped during
lockdown how did you find it
oh um i think um from teenagers
that just wanted to be out with their
friends uh to a little three-year-old
that wanted to climb up everything and
paint everything
um uh it was it was colorful to say the
least
um and i think like a lot of families
you know um the first six weeks were
quite trying
i i found myself unexpectedly um doing
um not a live tv show but pretty much
within 16 hours every day we were
filming the cooking show
that was very much um sort of covered
lock down based
about swappings and things you can do
and how you can be creative
with basic ingredients so that was never
expected but it kind of
kept me busy for a month but um i also
got some real quality time with my kids
and and my wife and um and of course i'm
grateful for that but um
what a time
[Music]
now to a remarkable achievement that
it's fair to say
takes two more than 18 000 miles covered
25 countries crossed and the world's
fastest tandem couple
are still in the same social bubble kat
dixon
and rasmussen have peddled their way
into the world record books
circumnavigating the globe on a tandem
in the fastest time ever
and i'm pleased to say that they both
join us now
80 to 100 miles a day for more than 250
days
what's on earth possessed you
it's hard to know when you say it like
that actually let's just talk about the
record though because this is not just
you breaking the women's tandem record
this is you breaking
the overall record the men did it in 281
days
you did it and a little over 263 how on
earth did you stuff the men so much
well i just think we kept going and we
didn't have many days off right now so
we
we cycled sort of across america didn't
work
with one day off again india one day off
personal highlights from you both
ah it's hard to kind of pick one but i
think
the big sur for me cycling down the
coast was extraordinary
beautiful sunsets and um sunrise morning
it's absolutely gorgeous
yeah no i think for me i love my mars so
we
we just left india and india was
brilliant but really phonetic and
the people there were just so courteous
and kind and
we could drink tea and it was uh it was
just lovely but there were so many
highlights i think it was a highlight in
every every country that we
we went through how on earth did you
stay friends
over the course of 260 odd days
traveling around the world with huge
physical effort as well
um it's moments but actually
when we were across it was very rarely
with each other
it was we had hunger we got if we were
very hungry
that was the biggest problem but i don't
think we were ever across with each
other particularly
no i think you know i think we're good
friends and i think it's about it's
about teamwork and it's about
understanding
each other and and trying to sort of
look after each other a bit as well
because
you know there was times when it was
really really hard and you know
it was just a question of looking out
for each other and making sure we'd
eaten and drank and all of those things
which were
you know some of the things that made it
made it much more sort of challenging i
think you know particularly when it was
difficult to get
food and things in various countries so
yeah
but we're still friends
a new study has found companies with
more female executives perform better
it suggests that listed firms where at
least one third of the bosses are women
have a profit margin
more than 10 times greater than those
without the research
also found that 15 percent of companies
in the ftse 350 have no
female executives at all financier and
campaigner dame helena morrissey
joins me now it's very interesting this
isn't it it's often been said that women
are
good at business and good for business
now you seem to have the research and
the numbers
to prove it yeah in fact it's not
new news really i mean these numbers are
really stark um
but actually there are reports going
back over a decade that suggests that
if you have a mixed gender team i mean
that's the key here it's not the women
are
so much better it's just that the
balance between men and women can really
make a big impact on a company's bottom
line
okay so is it men not appointing women
to key positions is it women not
applying for the key positions
what are the what are the issues that
you you're finding
so i think it's a bit of both because
obviously you have to look further back
to the women in executive roles you have
to look back at
the whole career pipeline this is option
called not a very pleasant expression
i'm afraid
but there are often women joining um all
the professions
all the careers are very well
represented these days um at the entry
level
you know more graduates are women these
days than men
um in countries like the uk so it's the
promotion
that isn't happening and many women stay
in the workforce but they end up
partly because often we have families
and and the policies just aren't sort of
female friendly around
or family friendly at that point in
women's lives
but i do fundamentally think it comes
down to this that women
are encouraged to behave like men to
adopt male trappings of power
to succeed and i think these results
that are released by this
report show actually when women can be
women when there's more than a third of
us
in in the boardroom or in the leadership
team then we can make a big
difference to a company but not if we
just the token and if we are
just you know they're left isolated in a
male-dominated environment
i mean your story is um um
you know a successful one so women
running things and
and and hugely successful businesses
what what are the qualities that that
they bring that perhaps men
men don't do you think i'm gonna have to
be careful not to make myself hugely
unpopular with all your male viewers
here but i do think on average
there are subtle differences and i think
women do tend to be
more collaborative like to sort of
regard themselves more like first among
equals rather than the big sort of
command control boss
and do tend to build a consensus and in
a day in a world where we have such
complex problems where nobody knows the
answers
i think that's more important than ever
before i think we need more of that
style of leadership
as we go out of the coronavirus crisis
and as we rebuild the economy so
you know these results that we've seen
may be just the start
in november of course americans will
cast their vote in the presidential
election electing either joe biden or
reelecting donald trump as president
well since mr trump took the seat in the
oval office
he's been a favorite subject of course
many comedians and satirists including
my next guest harry shearer
is a musician director and voice of
numerous characters from the simpsons
including mr burns smithers and ned
flanders and an album named the many
moods
of donald trump is his work as well very
good to talk to you harry now well tell
us about the many moods
of donald trump very true of course um
what is it and i've seen i've seen a
song you've done on youtube
yes uh well when i say the many moods of
donald trump as a
slight misnomer because i think there's
only one uh
aggressive defensiveness but uh the song
son-in-law is the first song from the
collection to be released
uh it's a tribute to jared kushner who
is his chief counselor about apparently
everything
the man whose uh portfolio expands to
the very limits of his incompetence
and uh this is a all the songs on this
collection
with one exception i perform in the
voice of donald trump
well let's give our audience a little
taste of it i mean it is
very weird well should i say eerie let's
have a look
[Music]
person i trust
spooky there you never know the
president might like it and uh
adopt it as part of his campaign music
who knows but listen let's talk about
the politics now
and um at the moment a lot of people
you know on the on the non-trump side
seem to be writing him off the polling's
bad
but you know this time four years ago
you could almost have said the same
thing
it would be wrong i suspect in your view
to to write off the president's chances
re-election campaigns for incumbents for
president america
always end up being referendums or
referenda
on the performance of the incumbent and
when you've
got a pandemic that's out of control and
derided and denounced by scientists
outside the country
as incompetent um and the results are
becoming
even more known to every american who
knows somebody
or somebody in their family who's fallen
victim to this
disease it's a lot harder to brag about
your performance as an incumbent
i've got to ask you about the simpsons
and in particular um the character that
i of course have
modeled my career on learnt an awful lot
from in the last 30 years
kent brockman um do you think he'd
approve i know you can't see me do you
think he'd approve of what i've turned
into
i i can see you as a matter of fact uh
the
technology is available to us here in
the uh control room at channel six
and uh i'm liking your suitings
now you might just recognize my next
guest as once a resident of ramsay
street
since she played nina tucker all those
years ago in the australian soap
neighbours
delta goodrem has pursued a triumphant
career as a singer and
songwriter act she's just released a new
single
called paralyzed let's take a listen
[Music]
pleased to say that delta joins us now
delta
lovely to see you this morning um i have
to say i've been besieged all morning by
delta goodrem france saying
you've got to get back to the united
kingdom sometime soon i suspect that
might be a little bit in the distance
but
at least lockdown has lifted where you
are i mean how has it been for you
i mean definitely well i'm sending all
my love to all my friends and supporters
out there in the uk
and and the second i can get there i
will be there in a heartbeat
um well basically i mean we're even in
our states everywhere is a little bit
different right
right now uh victoria's gone into a
heavier lockdown than new south wales
but
we're all just finding our way like all
of us and we're all feeling for our
fellow humans around the world and just
hoping to try to stay safe and do the
best job we all can
how on earth does one make music in
lockdown that isn't
incredibly sad incredibly poignant you
know incredibly pessimistic how do you
manage to get a major chord in there
that's a great question i i i had
written a lot of songs before going into
lockdown so i didn't know that
my next chapter i'd be back at the piano
isolating with so much time but
as fate would have it there was more
stories to tell but
even just being able to turn to music in
times like these is so important to be
able to
you know be able to escape into some
feelings and to be able to connect on
that level of sound
when you're expressing something on the
outside of what you're feeling on the
inside
is so important but i i went
into music so tell us a little bit then
about about the album and indeed about
the single paralyzed we were just
hearing it a second there i mean
have you been able to kind of inject
those uplifting vocals which you know
of course of course i mean i think it's
it's i've been out in this next album i
really started to tell
stories i'd never talked before and
whilst in lockdown of course i started
to do these live shows from my living
room and be able to
do any songs that people requested to
take the wool down invite people into
the living room but
being able to find empowering messages
in songs is so important to me it always
has been from the day that i started
best of luck with a good new single and
the album uh and yeah for all the fans
they do say you've got to get back here
as soon as you can thank you so much
neil sending much love in life
you